hey what's up everybody I'm here with my
buddy Edgar we're gonna go eat and
celebrate his birthday we're gonna need
some Asian food the exciting agar I am
hungry
you like Edgar hey what's up Mikey
you know [ __ ] vibes alright let's go
bro what's up guys that sounds taco
yacht
[Music]
Mikey say what's up any new emails come
in soon baby email coming yeah everybody
say happy birthday to Edgar
how are you turning that guy
[Music]
check it out
[Music]
happiness on top like
[Music]
what should get Rho sub agar-agar is
gonna be good today's my eating we're
not just it in our GoPro sure
Valencia
so I got honey calamansi juice
Kelly crunch and Mikey what you get
seasick what or China saucer
we found jeans for myself
[Music]
just doing a little thrifted yeah what's
so we at the supreme store
Mikey turn around Mikey turn around like
you bought a cup of supreme jacket let
me see the ass
[Music]
I
I'm still waiting to eat food right now
this is San Tong Chinese restaurant
number one
number two with a smaller menu let's get
a rundown with a jacket to the dragon
turn around turn around
this is the supreme baby with the drill
let's see the hat I go egg with the fat
hey what's up boy so we got inside
everything always works out there's like
a 30-minute wait but they let us in
[Music]
that's in the menu look at the menu boys
chicken all right so this is a homie
from SF what's that go to stuff tell us
the original drug fried chicken okay we
copy that we copy one of those what else
what else the appetizers are pretty good
what's your goat your appetizers if
someone goes here full of regular pasta
goes dry steam ones if you like you like
you know a little softer this is the
Chinese place yep your Chinese or yeah
me too bro all right shows other cool
stuff that we're gonna get tonight some
noodles here these are like how are you
getting noodles that I don't know get
some noodles which one no so it's sliced
peach oh he can't Oh shrimp and calamari
oh that sounds delicious yodelice you
also say something in Spanish
[Laughter]
so anchor what are you most looking
forward to to eating tonight chicken and
dumpling dumpling she love dumplings how
about your bike
you love chicken right that's your life
at that orange soda hey so what kind of
chicken is is tiny star you saying in
Chinese
it's like a blaze like look how detailed
it is on my friend hey guys check out
this hat with Michael today our emo
designer and the producer stuff you guys
already know my emo designer my techie
we've done my personal driver and eater
and then we got my boy right for some
personal eater
we're now we got a black soy bean sauce
noodles with a calamari shrimp and and
so foo beef and tofu look at that
glistening oh my goodness
[Music]
hey you go there you go oh my god it's
not like delicious
hi so the noodles
what kind of dumplings are these um
Alonso pork dumplings and then what kind
of fried rice is this combination shrimp
or me um you're telling me a fit a
shrimp fried this rice
so right now Edgar's eating chicken he's
trying to himself good because he
couldn't eat the chicken properly
earlier so hopefully he finishes his
ring correctly yeah eat the chicken
correctly see this is not a chicken eat
everything Carla it's all that
alright so Michael took a bite what's
your fortune read it out laughs
everybody okay
let it focus you have a charming way
with words send an email to a friend
okay okay come on Sophie yeah he's like
I hope it's with my friends my friends I
said Ram hey just read it say they don't
hey that's not the B bro no yeah maybe
you two a date that's today let me see
this let me see let's see if you really
got to see one of them oh that's Maya
all right can you love it see what
Pikachu get this triangle Center on me
Nathan guys this is fine I'm talking
about baby see it alright you can turn
off ok so right now we're trying to
figure out if we have to pay for parking
I don't know with the bear not we're
good
12:00 a.m. to 12:00 a.m. with a 12:00
a.m. to 4:30 12:00 a.m.
I don't know alright so you can't really
see it but we're trying to go to Purple
Cow I think our number is twelve bro
okay so we just finished eating Chinese
food it's pretty delicious
it was delicious
I'm 12
I looked well-versed green okay so
wasn't chicken lending
beanie so I got we're at purple towel I
got the matzo chocolate latte
what did you get what you get Alonso Oh
DJ's don't do what you get I got the
Thai cheese okay okay how about you add
then no truck chocolatey okay with Bobo
right sugar
oh wow diet I got mine with milk
my name is pretty good it's pretty good
how about you Mikey how about you mister
mine